consider the table with function values
for f of x is equal to x squared over
one minus cosine x at positive x values
near zero
notice that there is one missing value
in the table this is the missing one
right here use a calculator to evaluate
f of x at x equals 0.1 and enter this
number in the table rounded to the
nearest thousandth from the table what
does the one-sided limit x is the limit
as x approaches zero from the positive
direction as x squared of x squared over
1 minus cosine of x appear to be so
let's see what they did they evaluated
when x equals 1 f of x is 2.175
when x gets even a little bit closer to
0 and once again we're approaching 0
from values larger than zero that's what
this little superscript positive tells
us we're at 0.5 and we're at 2.042
then when we get even closer to 0
0.2 f of x is 2.007
and so i'm guessing when i'm getting
even closer it's going to be even closer
to 2 right over here but let's verify
that get my calculator out
so
i want to evaluate x squared over 1
minus cosine of x when x is equal to
0.1
so the first thing i want to actually
let me let me actually verify that i'm
in let me verify that i'm in radian mode
because otherwise i might get a strange
answer so i am in radian mode
and so let me evaluate it so i'm going
to have 0.1
0.1 squared
over
let me do
divided by 1
minus
cosine of 0.1
and this gets me
2.0016 and let's see they want us to
round to the nearest thousandth so that
would be 2.002
type that in 2.002
and so it looks like the limit is
approaching the limit is approaching 2.
it's not approaching 2.005 we just
crossed 2.005 from 2.007 to 2.002
so let's check our answer and we got it
right i always find it fun to visualize
these things and that's what a graphing
calculator is good for it can actually
graph things so let's let's graph this
right over here so go into graph mode
let me redefine my function here so
let's see it's going to be x
squared
divided by
minus cosine of x
cosine of x
and then let me make sure that the range
of my graph is right so i'm zoomed in at
the right at the right part that i care
about so let me go to the range
and let's see i care about approaching x
from the or approaching 0 from the
positive direction but as long as i as
long as i see values around 0 i should
be fine and act but i could actually
zoom in a little bit more so i can make
the my minimum x value and let me make
it negative one
negative one let me make my maximum x
value the maximum x value here is one
but just to get some space here i'll
make this
1.5
so the x scale is one y minimum it seems
like we're approaching two so the y max
can be much smaller let's see let me
make y max three and now let's graph
this thing
so let's see what it's doing
it looks like
and you see here
whether and actually it looks like
whether you're approaching from the
positive direction or from the negative
direction it looks like you're
approaching the value of the function
approaches 2. but this problem we're
only caring about as we as we have x
values that are approaching zero from
values larger than zero so this is the
limit this is the one-sided limit that
we care about but the two shows up right
over here as well